how are you guys doing today
good how are you again stephen uh it is
great to see both of you i'm a big fan
of both of your work so it's always nice
to help you promote whatever you're
working on thank you who's on your shirt
i can't see
uh it it may be spikey scorsese and
harvey keitel yeah that's pretty it was
cut off a little can you imagine if i
was like never heard of him
[Laughter]
the scorsese guy will eventually land on
his feet you know
he'll be okay um so you guys all work
together on saint vincent i'm just
curious how long had the three of you um
talking about obviously
uh theodore as well um been talking
about working together again
i mean this is mine and chris's third
time with bridesmaids saint vincent and
this and um
i i just like once ted called me and
immediately we were like oh the goal
would be if we can get oh dowd and
there's a reason you keep going back to
the same people
one th they're
if they're really really good
cheap
not doing anything else
two
um
but you know
it's like you you go back to the same
people where you're like they love they
they love what they do they're
exceptional at it and they're a joy to
be around and if you can get that in one
package and
he has an irish accent you just go with
it
that's really all it takes
yeah i'm also very lucky to be involved
i feel i feel like um it was a script i
read a few years ago and uh the roads
were the other way around and then it
came around this time and ted said that
melissa was doing and i was like well
that makes much more sense actually well
done everybody for working that out i
would have told you if you had asked
um but of course i was really
such a gorgeous
story and a story that needs to be told
and an interesting character to to get
your teeth stuck into so
we've always enjoyed working together
before and i hope we do it again yeah
yeah i think that the way that the
script got for people don't realize it
was a blacklist script and originally
the you know uh anyway people do some
research
the roles are reversed i think it's much
better this way the way you guys what
people don't talk a lot about strangely
is like they're
they change the the
roles in the
league characters but also the the
starting used to be penguins
it's very different um
and so it was a it was different because
they would have to troll them
wow for a minute steven you he had you
for a minute you were like what right
yeah no
yeah a hundred a hundred percent you
know i actually want to talk about um i
want to actually talk about something
specific i've been uh i'm
i'm always curious about actor how
actors like to prepare for filming like
a big scene and i want to specifically
use a scene from this movie for the two
of you i'm talking about the hospital
scene it's a phone call and both of you
guys have to sort of deliver these
emotional performances and i'm just
curious how do you actually get ready
when you know on say a monday i'm going
to need to cry i'm going to need to go
there i'm going to need to bring it are
you days in advance breaking down what
you want to do could you sort of or is
it sort of the day before you're really
getting ready
i'm i mean for me i am i'm a
nerdy over preparer
i i write it i i say it out loud i write
it i usually stay two weeks two weeks
ahead of myself
and it's almost like if i if it's just
all by rote
i mean it's always different every time
but i think if i had to say it i usually
over prepared and then i hope in the
moment on the day i throw it all out and
i just wait and see what happens
i try to never plan
how i'm going to do it i try to almost
say it mechanically i think i feel it
but as it gets closer to shooting it i
try not to have any emotion about it and
almost read it like a list of numbers
and then i let it
all happen because i'm afraid if i start
to
conjure things i'll be imitating it
instead of doing it
if that makes any sense
it actually does
i i'm not dissimilar i probably think
about
if it's a very
if it's a particularly heavy scene
coming up you want to get yourself into
with the emotional state for it as much
as the the words will always be kind of
easy enough so it's really just about
getting yourself into the headspace and
the headspace in this particular film at
times
it's a very difficult place to be in you
know especially if you've got kids of
your own
it's you have to imagine
the one thing that
is almost unimaginable
and
in a way that's the only way to bring
truth to it and to do justice to all the
people who have lost
and so i gear myself up in an emotional
way
in terms of like
reading accounts and maybe listening to
some stuff
and
and just to make sure that i'm right for
the top of the same and then let you
know the actual performance of us all
and the other character you know what
melissa is such a great listener you
know when she's
in a scene and i'm sure it's because of
i think to do improv well you have to be
a good listener
and
so it always felt like the scenes that
we were doing were
very you know without being cliche they
were in the moment we were present
for what was happening and not
coming up with shtick and and shoveling
it out it always felt very real and
truthful so
once you realize that that's
that's the rules then then it's much
easier to do
[Music]
you guys got to have kevin kline in the
movie i'm obviously a huge fan of kevin
klein and he's relatively selective
about his projects melissa i need to
know what it was like working with him
and chris at what point were you ready
to rage quit the shoot when you found
out you didn't have any scenes with him
oh you get the one
i do i get a scene with them yeah i get
a scene with them towards the end
yeah
i might i must have decent i screwed
this up i didn't remember that scene
that's all right that's a good review
yeah
it's when he comes to visit chris oh i
shouldn't i don't want to give it away
but he cut he comes he goes
yeah yeah i just got it yeah but
you know what it was it was an uh beyond
a dream
i think at no point
you know
coming up in this business
was i ever is insane or cocky or nuts
enough to be like i bet i'll probably
work with kevin like words words never
said by myself
so
when he actually said yes to it and he
is so selective um because he can be
he's kevin kline
um
feeling his
he is so
lovely and charming and funny
christ he's funny
and then also
lovely when you're in a scene with him
what makes him kevin klein is right
there it's nothing he's only the
character
he's completely open to anything going
on and it was just
it was an absolute joy